now a very special guest guido buchwald
a defensive linchpin in west germany's
1990 world cup winning side and the man
who marked diego maradona out of the
final
who better to ask for an expert's view
on the new world champions
how does winning the world cup affect
you
it's the biggest title in the game
for all of the people in germany and the
whole world cares about it ultimately
so you get a lot more acknowledgement
obviously and fame
what i also liked was getting more
respect from rival fans too after
winning the world cup in 90.
foreign did in brazil was really special
it was time to win the world cup again
after waiting 24 years
big teams win trophies and these guys
came close so many times but now they've
shown they're a top side
since an absolutely
the first non-south americans to win
there amazing
to that the semi-final
and it's obvious what a superb side this
is
and they deserved everything
this is a
at the start a lot of people wanted to
see him dropped
but he got totally stuck in and for me
he was the one outstanding player
a lot of others too like thomas miller
i reckon 80 of them played at the very
highest level
absolutely
how do you see german football
developing will the team remain dominant
yes we'll continue to feature at the top
and stay in the top three of world
football
you can't win the world cup or euros all
the time
and we're bound to lose games now and
again
but i see us carrying on down this road
and at the top for decades to come
the future looks great
do you see
that when he push defoes senior how do
you rate the progress of coach yogi
lewis
he's improved on the job
he's also learned that there are some
situations as a club coach or a national
coach where you will make mistakes
that's normal
everybody's looking at you with millions
of armchair experts in homes across
germany
i think he's done a good job of keeping
calm and going his own way
he's developed really well over the last
10 years
and is now a hot name around the world
yeah he's complicated
you